our first speaker this afternoon is
Sasha sure stuff who will tell us about
algorithmic the key notion in this work
is that of epsilon approximate degree so
let's fix an arbitrary function could be
a real function of boolean functions the
epsilon approximate degree of F is the
minimum degree of a real polynomial that
approximates F point wise within epsilon
so this notion is very naturally forced
to find a long time ago in 1992 by a
nice emissivity in their pioneering work
where they proved in particular that a
polynomial of degree root n is
sufficient and necessary to approximate
the or function so throughout this talk
I'll use this shorthand notation for
epsilon approximate degree since its
introduction this notion has found a
variety of applications both the lower
bounds and upper bounds are of interest
the lower bounds typically give you
impossibility results in hardness
results for other models such as circuit
complexity quantum query complexity
communication complexity and there's
been a lot of progress along those lines
using approximate degree as a vehicle to
solve hard open problems upper bounds an
approximate degree are also of interest
they typically give you algorithms such
as learning theoretical occations more
generally applications to algorithm
design and other applications as well as
such as differential privacy sometimes
upper bounds also give you lower bounds
as was shown by Avishai in his work on
and or formulas okay a watershed moment
for this quantity came with the
publication of this work in 98 by Beals
Berman Cleve Mosca and the wolf so they
made the following simple but absolutely
crucial pivotal observations a quantum
query algorithm for a function with T
queries automatically gives you an
approximating polynomial for the same
function of degree
so having a quantum algorithm for a
function gives you automatically a
polynomial approximating that function
that has the same complexity and since
then virtually all known upper bounds an
approximate degree have come from
quantum algorithms so this is both good
and bad certainly the community has
benefited immensely from the quantum
method but there are problems at
limiting our our two box to the quantum
techniques so what why is that
problematic
first of all quantum polynomials
typically are not constructive you can
sometimes derive the approximating
polynomial from the algorithm if you try
hard enough but in cases in some cases I
mean I should say in most cases of
non-trivial complexity such as the
element distinctness function the
polynomial that you reconstruct recover
in this fashion is so complex that it's
as good as no polynomial at all so
they're not constructive there are
typically more complicated than a
construction from first principles and
finally and this is the most important
point there are examples where they're
less efficient than polynomials so the
first point you can sort of live with
the second point is is perhaps more of a
big deal but the third point is really a
deal breaker in this talk we're going to
look at a number of break through
quantum query algorithms and in each
case we're going to design a first
principles approximating polynomial for
the same function with the proof fitting
on half a page or in one page in all
cases we're going to match well so I'll
take advantage of some modularity and in
there there will be some common
components to the proofs which I'll
factor out and then that that won't
count
the length of the individual troops but
when we see the proofs hopefully you'll
agree that they are dramatically simpler
and and they're there their first
principles the only preliminary to
following this presentation is it's the
chebyshev polynomial nothing else okay
and performance-wise we're going to
match quantum or improve the improve it
polynomial ii so in particular as our
main theorem we're going to exhibit the
first natural problem with a polynomial
gap between approximate degree and
quantum query complexity okay so let's
get started as a warm-up we'll look at
symmetric functions so let f be an
arbitrary symmetric function and let's
say that it is constant on having on
inputs of Hamming weight between K and n
minus K so this is just in the nature of
things this turns out to be the right
characterization for symmetric functions
then it's epsilon approximate degree is
given by this expression you might
wonder why we even care about all
epsilon as opposed to a small cost of
epsilon as is usually the case
well the metric functions are used as a
building block in most constructions
involving approximation by polynomials
so much so that you actually need tight
approximating polynomials for the
symmetric functions for all ranges of
Epsilon
and you'll see that later in this talk
as well okay so this gives you a
complete characterization of the epsilon
approximate degree prior to this work
the theorem was known only so the
theorem was known but the only proof was
due to Ronald D wolf from 2008 and the
proof that you'll see is an explicit and
first principles proof so actually the
paper has three proofs for this theorem
but you'll see one of them there's a
combinatorial proof and two
approximation theoretic proofs that have
nothing to do
sometimes the Silvermist symmetric in
here around and over too but the lower
bound is no I mean the upper band is no
so a very good point yeah so actually
you don't need the symmetry assumption
for the upper bound in fact the theorem
holds for all functions that vanish in
this range where it is constantly
symmetric about n over two it's between
Kane and minus K all right
case at most n over two okay case it's
most about you have n times K ok this
turns out to be the right expression
yeah ok so this is just to get us
started the next step the next function
will look at is element distinctness
that really is the key one perhaps the
most studied problem in quantum querier
complexity other than search so there's
been a lot of work on this problem the
problem is given n integers from a range
of size R determine whether the integers
are pairwise distinct so typically
traditionally the input is represented
by a matrix of size n by r so the N rows
correspond to the n elements and the N
columns correspond to the possible
values that each element can take so in
the I throw you put a 1 in the jf column
if the value of the I element is the J
value of the universe ok so the input
matrices have exactly 1 1 in each row
and so we'll consider a more more
general set up when we're you're given
an arbitrary boolean matrix of order n
by r with at most and once we don't care
how they are placed within the matrix it
really doesn't matter and then the
function is defined by 1 if there's a
row with if there's no rule with with a
repeated entry
and as your otherwise so you can
consider a generalization of this
problem to K distinctness where the
parameter K is set to 2 in the version
that I just described in general you're
looking for a capable of repeated
elements and here I'm the the answer
that we obtained is this so it looks
somewhat somewhat strange when you see
for the first time but magically it it's
precisely the quantity that Belov's
obtains in in his quantum algorithm that
uses a completely different technique so
below this proof is arguably one of the
most advanced proofs in quantum query
complexity and it's based on this
beautiful powerful framework of learning
graphs so he gets the exact same answer
using a different completely different
set of tools so this gives me hope that
this is actually in the nature of things
so this is the true answer but as of
today it's open
even in terms of K and so so the problem
is parametrized by this constant K and
all other parameters can be arbitrary so
the constant the constant within the Big
O notation depends on K own so you mean
that 1/2 minus 1 over 4 1 minus 2 so I
strongly believe that it is but this is
only known to be true for K equals 2
it's it's a difficult problem
okay and the last result that that we
look at is KD n FS this is perhaps the
most flexible or general class of
functions in quantum query complexity
here you can handle arbitrary properties
that have K certificate complexity or
case one certificate complex stores your
certificate complexity at most K so here
the bound that we obtain is this the
variables that are inputs to your books
it's your KD n F 4k CNF could be there
could be infinitely many of them so this
is an important point there there's this
results this result holds for the
setting where the function has as its
input bits arbitrarily many variables
but the only restriction that you make
use of is that the Hamming weight of the
inputs could be at most and so under
that promise the bound holds so this
reproves and generalizes the best
previous quantum lower bound the
trombonist who used again a
sophisticated algorithm based on a
random walk a quarter walk on the
johnson craft okay up to this point
every single result i've talked about
has been a new proof of something that
we already knew from quantum techniques
which brings me to the final slide of
the results overview the surjectivity
function the surjectivity function is
similar to the element distinctness
function again you're given n elements
from a range of size R and you're asked
whether the entire range is covered so
the input is exactly the same it's
formatted exactly the same but what you
need to compute is is different okay so
this is the formulaic description of the
function
in a beautiful result Paul and his
student vallata
much Moochie proved that this problem
has linear approximate degree a linear
quantum query complexity so they
exhibited the first problem in AC zero
that has maximal quantum query
complexity and this was a very
comforting piece of news it was a
conjectured agreed upon I should say or
hypothesized by all experts that this is
also the right answer for approximate
degree which which would have a variety
of other applications so that would be a
terrific terrific state of affairs if
that were true but as it is surjectivity
decided otherwise and it turned out that
it does not have linear approximate
degree so we disprove this conjecture
that the approximate degree of this
function is and and in reality it turns
out to be n to the 3/4 at the most
okay when you compare the linear the
linear complexity for algorithms versus
the complexity of n to the 3/4 for
polynomials you get a polynomial gap
between the two quantities so
polynomials outperform quantum
algorithms possible good question I
think it's it's a power of two or a
power of five five halves so no such
thing so it this isn't this isn't the
largest quantitatively this isn't the
largest gap so in his original work
under some bias exhibited a specially
constructed function that has a gap
between approximate degree and
polynomial degree when I say that this
is the first natural function by that I
mean that the function has been studied
on its own merits and it's of interest
in its in its own right and you know
what's not explicitly constructed with
the purpose of separating the two
complexity measures okay so this
completes the result so review and now
we'll jump into the technical part of
the talk as promised the only
preliminary that you need for the proofs
is knowledge of the chebyshev polynomial
which is this family of polynomials
there extremal in a very precise sense
it's a staple in approximation theory
they're bounded the unit interval by one
in absolute value and they exhibit
extremely growth beyond the unit
interval at every point
okay so given this only tool as our as
our starting point we develop two
higher-order preliminaries higher-order
primitives I should say that are of
interest I think well outside the scope
of this work the first is a very natural
approximation theoretic problem I call
it the extension problem so here you're
given a function defined on inputs of
Hamming weight up to M and you would
like and you have an approximate for
four F four inputs of Hamming we're up
to them now you're considering an
extension of F two inputs of Hamming
weight and an extension defined
naturally by setting the functions
output to be zero on the new inputs so
approximation theoretically you'd like
to know whether an approximate for
little F can be converted somehow in a
blackbox manner to an approximate for
big F so it would be terrific if that
were true unfortunately
that turns out to be impossible if you
think about it for a few minutes you
realize that there's a simple counter
example but morally speaking the
statement is true what you can do is you
can start with an approximate for the
extension of F to inputs of length to M
and from then on once you have that the
approximate for that for that initial
extension extending it further beyond 2m
is very inexpensive so this is the
theorem that we proved once you have an
approximate for the extension of F to
inputs of Hamming weight to M extending
it any further is extremely efficient so
you're paying at a multiplicative cost
of n over m the square root of that and
there's this additive error term and the
theorem is tight with respect to all
parameters
okay so our general-purpose primitive
that will be used in think all of the
proofs okay the other primitive concerns
functions that can be expressed as
boolean inner product if you will so
it's a function of this form where you
have X 1 ended with fi initialize a
function on some universe
okay so the X and the y parts are
tightly coupled and you know we could
hope to understand the approximate
degree of any disjunction of the F in
our applications the F's will be DNFs so
you're going from akkadian F to a K
minus 1 DN f 2i k minus 2 EMF this is
the case and you know and all these
settings like key element distinctness
and we can also hope to understand the X
part separately but they're coupled here
so the contribution of the decoupling
theorem is to decouple the X part and
the y part so for any B we prove this
upper bound on the approximate degree so
you're approximating the X part
separately you're approximating the y
part separately secure you're
approximating disjunctions of the FS and
here you're approximating dysfunctions
of the X's and then you're able to merge
the results so this holds for every B
and if you optimize over B carefully as
we do in the in applications of the
statement you get tight balance okay so
these are the preliminaries now let's
see the proofs and hopefully hopefully I
can justify the comment I made earlier
to Tarak oh that they fit on half a page
alright let's let's start with with the
easiest proof so you're given a
symmetric function and that is constant
on inputs of Hamming weight between K
and M minus K then it's approximate
agree with the error parameter set
epsilon is that without loss of
generality let's consider it bounded
let's consider it let's examine our
one-sided version of this theorem I mean
once we have the one-sided version then
we have function that that's 0 on 0
everywhere except for inputs of Hamming
weight at least and at most N
and - case or just personally anyway so
the theorem we'll we'll look at is your
given a function that is constant on
impulse of hanging Hamming weight
greater than K and this is the bound
that we want to prove we will not use
the centry assumption at all so how does
the proof work well you consider the
function and you extend it to inputs of
Hamming weight k plus log 1 over epsilon
and since the function is 0 everywhere
above the K its level of the hypercube
we can extend it further two inputs of
this Hamming weight that'll be a
legitimate extension of the original
function what you're really interested
in is the extension of the original
function to inputs of Hamming weight n
so here's the proof it's one line in
fact
this is the original function right you
are going to compute it to zero error on
inputs of Hamming weight at most 2k plus
log 1 over Epsilon once you have this
initial initial function you're going to
extend it well this is this is your
starting point the blue the blue shaded
area here and once you have that you're
going to extend it to the entire domain
you're paying an additive term of log 1
over Epsilon and this is the
multiplicative term so what is this
number so here we are we're just going
to use straight interpolation so the
most inefficient the most brute-force
approach this is at most I mean you can
compute any function on inputs of
Hamming weight at most K by a polynomial
of degree K just by straight
interpolating it
so you don't need you don't need any of
this it's straight interpolation I'm not
hiding anything the polynomial does not
need to be that's that's the the
extension problem is that you you only
you only deal with it on inputs of
length of Hamming weight up to something
and then beyond that you're just going
to extend effortlessly so you don't have
a priori have no control over the
approximate on those inputs to which you
try to extend
okay in the paper there are two more
proofs one of which is competent toriel
okay now let's look at search activity
where we get the separation of quantum
algorithms from polynomials so here the
theorem that would prove is if your
range has size R then we we can we can
show a sharper bound in all cases and
would prove a bound of size n to the 3/4
ok let's see how this works let's just
write the function down as it is defined
and the outside gate the outer gate
we're going to approximate by
championship so then we have this
expression all I've done here is
approximate they on gate by chebyshev
polynomial and you know everything about
chebyshev polynomials that you could
ever ask so if you multiply this out you
get a linear combination of these well
let's let's first flip them so that
they're monomials so I'm going to use
demorgan's law to switch them to
monomials and now I'm going to multiply
this out
now the coefficients of the chebyshev
polynomial are bounded by two to the
degree of the chebyshev polynomial so
when you multiply out you get a linear
combination of terms where the sum of
the coefficients is bounded
and once you have that you take the
terms one by one you rip the term out
you replace it by an approximating
polynomial with air inversely /
inversely related to this quantity and
then you plug that back into the sump
so this shows this really shows the
power of of polynomials versus quantum
algorithms because you can't do that
that kind of surgery on a quantum
polynomial you can't hope to consider
the approximating polynomial and rip out
an individual term and replace it by
something completely different you just
don't have control at that at that
physical level a level of the
approximating object and perhaps this is
also a good a good place to explain the
the title of this talk algorithmic
polynomials the informal message of this
work is that if we are interested if we
need polynomials as we do for learning
applications or applications to
differential privacy complexity
theoretical applications sometimes we do
not care where the polynomial comes from
so we should construct them from first
principles and the approach of this work
is to use approximation Theory
traditional approximation theory which
is used to prove these extension theorem
and to couple decoupling theorem along
with basic principles of algorithmic
designs such as divide and conquer
sampling arguments inclusion exclusion
so the approach of this work is aptly
called algorithmic polynomials because
the focus is on polynomials as opposed
to algorithms
okay now let's look at the harder to
theorems the hardest two theorems of
this work here we'll look at KT NF
formulas and this is the bound that we
are aiming for again the formula has as
its inputs begin variables the formula
is a KD NF and you're bound should not
have a dependence on begin it should
only depend on the maximum Hamming
weight of the inputs in your domain
so let's fix some notation let D of NK
epsilon be the maximum approximate
degree mapped maximum epsilon
approximate degree over K DNFs on an
arbitrary domain where the Hamming
weight is founded by Litwin the number
of variables is infinity then from first
principles by interpolation we get this
bound
and then using the decoupling theorem
you get this alternate bound so how is
this exactly applied well a KD NF is a K
minus 1 DN f a sequence of K minus 1 TN
apps coupled with individual bits by
definition so your approximate the
individual bits or rather disjunctions
of individual bits separately you
approximate the k minus 110 f DN f
separately and then you get this
expression
there's a slight technicality there
where you have to deal with negations
but that's that's that's that that can
be taken care of okay so when you solve
this recurrence you get this expression
which is the claimed here it should be K
plus 1 which is the claimed upper bound
okay and the last result I'll sketch for
you is element distinctness here you're
given an arbitrary matrix of size n by r
and you'd like to figure out if some row
has greater than K entries of 1 so this
is the bound that we are again we're
going to define this parameter is
quantity d of n R K and epsilon so it's
the maximum of all functions that can be
expressed as the disjunction of our
parts each part is a threshold predicate
with the threshold parameter set to K
and threshold predicates are applied to
disjoint sets of variables so this is a
generalization of element distinctness
and the size of the underlying universe
can be unbounded so here the proof is
slightly more delicate again you start
with a bound that uses just approximate
just interpolation straight
interpolation that is that is the base
case of your inductive argument then you
use the extension theorem and the
decoupling theorem to come up with two
complementary upper bounds for the
inductive step
the first bound is useful when the
number of parts is small so the number
of values is small and you are looking
for a key repetition of some value so
this uses the extension theorem alone
here you assume that you have infinitely
many parts so the number of range items
could be infinite and the number of
elements is at most n and you have this
complimentary bound when you combine
them
and solve the recurrence and you get
this answer which is what what I
promised on the first line okay
so now let me get to the open problems
the most compelling open problem that
arises naturally from this work is
whether there's a funk is whether every
function in depth to a zero has a
proximate degree bounded away from an so
bound approximate degree of n to the 1
minus epsilon D for some positive
epsilon sub D so prior to this work the
consensus was that this definitely is
not the case and surjectivity in fact is
just such a function that should have
linear approximate degree but at this
point there is no reason to believe that
this is ruled out there are some
candidates such as approximate majority
but their status is highly uncertain and
I would be I think I think both both
directions both outcomes are equally
likely okay this is a this is a workshop
on the lower bound so let's have three
problems that have to do with lower
bounds now they have the natural ones
show that the upper bounds and this work
are tight and as of today this is only
known for search activity this was
solved in a beautiful paper by von
qatari and Thaler so mark is going to
talk about that work next so that paper
uses these the sub linear upper bound on
surjectivity
as inspiration to prove lower bounds on
a number of other problems the status of
the other two problems remains wide open
there are difficult problems both KD n F
and K element distinctness they've seen
a lot of work yeah both of these
problems have seen a lot of work and
it's not clear quite how to proceed
okay one other exciting bit of progress
that I should mention is there's a paper
by Marc Justin and Robin that was posted
I think literally a few days ago on NCCC
that makes progress on the first point
so the author's use the technique in the
dish in the surjectivity proof that I
just showed you iteratively right so
surjectivity is depth too if you have a
circuit of depth D and you apply the
same technique iteratively then you get
an upper bound of maybe not and to the
3/4 but something that is still sub
linear so if your if your circuit has a
number of gates that bounded it but
that's bounded by n then the hypothesis
is true so these authors prove that the
answer is yes if your circuit has linear
size you know in general the status of
this question remains wide open yes so
all three all three problems here are
quite I think very fundamental and very
challenging so there are fun problems to
work on
give you what mark sets up
[Music]
that's a great question
right so that's another powerful result
proved breakthrough result I should say
proved using quantum techniques and no
classical proof is known great question
right right right right
yeah yeah it would be great to have a
classical proof for that as well the
result is of interest well outside of
quantum query complexity